This guy is named Slug. Slug created
"Space War." If you go to the
Computer History Museum on most weekends,
Slug will come and kick your ass on the
machine behind him which is the machine
that Space War was invented on in 1951
61 (my apologies) so you can go there (1961)
and the guy who invented that computer
history will come and kick your ass.
This is very important because that is how
constricted our online history is. Like
the web is this little you know when I
say the web is an eye blink in the
history of humanity, right, it's like
5,000 years from 'like oh my god a rock'
to Kim Kardashian and then it's
one millisecond to this, right?
And also, for some people who care,
there's no hover hand I touched him.
I touched the man. I love him. Again, life
is a lossy format, but software is not
quite a lossy format. It likes to be
completely together. And that's where
luck comes in. So there's a thing I've
been working on for about three years,
this is what I started working on when
Brewster hired me. One of things he said
to me was: 'I would like for you---
we've been doing pretty good with the web,
we've been okay with the web. We've been
pretty good with books. We're actually
doing good with music (we have a lot of
music). We have a whole lot of movies.
But what about software? How do we do things
with software?' And the reason that movies
and music persist is because we can play them.
And not only can we play them,
but we play them like nothing. Like if
I'm like "Oh god listen to how terrible this band is."
The time from "Man, what are you
talking about?" to "You're right they suck!"
can be like five seconds. That's amazing!
Isn't that amazing? Like you forget,
it's like "Oh my God, look what this cat is doing
on top of... riding this Roomba... boom!
You're looking at cat on Roomba!
The world's a little dumber but you did it.
2 seconds. So why don't we have that with software?
This is the moment when my mind got blown!
This is a game called "Smurf Rescue"
from ColecoVision. Let's go back to it.
In it you pilot a smurf. He has to jump
over those things and meet Smurfette.
Very simple. For the ColecoVision.
But over the course of two and a half years
we got it to run in a browser in JavaScript.
And here's the thing about that...
First of all 'Why would you do that
abomination against all of man and Lord and...!'
Okay, so the thing is is that
right now the way to get to everybody is
the web. The way that we get there is
using a browser. And the thing in browsers that
has not been destroyed by Larry Ellison is JavaScript.
JavaScript is in everything (like it or not)
and technology has been done to turn
JavaScript into the end run for a compiler.
Without going into the full technical details,
because they're all up there, the point is
we were able to take a emulator called MESS, the
Multi Emulator Super System, that has 1600 platforms
everything from Sega Genesis
to (Atari) 2600 to the ColecoVision
and be able to make it play stuff
in your browser basically in full speed.
The first time we got it running it ran at
14% speed. We had it in
70% speed within two weeks.
We had 24 systems running at
100%  speed, and it's gone on like that.
We have been able to do all
these different systems. We have old
stuff from Atari. All these are running
in JavaScript. Here's a chess system from
01979. Here's "Spy Versus Spy". We've even
gotten to the point--so, you know that's
that's neat... and it's up there, if you go
to archive.org, you go to /software...
Boom! You could say to somebody:
"I can't believe someone made a game about this.
There it is!" Okay. So...
from there it gets really weird and scary.
Because now once we've been able to make a machine
run in a machine, where to go from there?
Well, we have something I call...
"The Emularity." This is windows running
inside of a browser. And we actually have
it booting up... so that's JavaScript.
And we've actually gotten PPP to work,
so that the browser can connect through PPP...
out of the browser into the Internet.
So it's connecting to textfiles.com using
the Mosaic browser... and
is able to connect... so it's a 01994 browser
inside of a 01993 operating system that's
running inside of a 02015 browser that's
running inside of a 02013 operating system. Right?
We're here now! Now just to be clear
the current Internet does not like you...
Whitehouse.gov is like... what are you?
Forsooth! I cometh with the Magna Carta,
to bringeth to you... but that's what
we... okay, fine, I understand that...
but the best part is it actually
leaves something in the log so it'll
actually say... well, 16-bit Windows 3.1
Netscape 1.0 stopped by...
that'll blow your metrics right the heck out!